The Joe Rogan Experience out of all the
people that perform music and travel and
are as prominent as you are you're
you're probably one of the most
outspoken and informed when it comes to
issues on foreign policy and human
rights and how when did this become a
big part of your life and when did
discussing this publicly become a big
part of your life
well it became a big part of my life
the day my father died I think I mean I
wouldn't know because I was only five
months old my father has
you might or may not know data anzio
on the 18th of February 1944 and I was
born September 43 so it was only a few
months old
but when it when I started to understand
some of this was when he didn't come
home and start picking me up from school
when I was a little kid
and then
all through my childhood
I lived I was brought up by my mother my
brother and my big brother John and I
were brought up single-handed by my mum
who was a school teacher but she was
also very left-wing
she's an interesting woman because
she came from a very kind of middle
class family in London
funnily enough they lived in golders
green which was sort of well known for
being a Jewish community in North London
um her father ran a ran a business that
was sort of middleman in fancy Goods
toys and things like that so there was a
big Warehouse in London and but my
mother and she went off to a boarding
school girls school so she was very
brought up in a very fairly straight
laced English Christian Middle Class way
she then trained as a teacher on her
first teacher training
was in a town called Bradford which is
in the north of London and not north of
London north of England far north of
England in Yorkshire
and it was a huge eye-opener to her
there she was first winter comes along
it's really cold there's a foot of snow
on the floor and she suddenly notices
that half the kids in her class are
walking to school with no shoes
and something went Bing
this would have been in 1935 36
something like that and she suddenly
went
what and she started to look into the
social conditions there in the
industrial North
and and even then in the in the mid to
late 30s she understood that there were
inequalities in the context of the
society that she lived in that that she
felt her personal need to do something
about and she became extremely left-wing
um anyway
cut to later on so our front room was
always a labor Party Committee room and
she was always off in the evenings
canvassing elections or and dragging me
of my brother to British China
friendship Association meetings in the
evening and but she was always very
careful and clear with us that she would
I remember one day she said to me and my
brother when we come back from a meeting
interestingly enough at the Friends
Meeting House which is the place that
Quakers meet you know in it wherever it
is in the world it's always called the
Friends Meeting House
and we've been watching films of K-pop
clad Chinese you know soldiers fighting
against Chiang Kai-shek and the
Nationalist puppet government and blah
blah blah blah blah and she said you
know where we've been tonight don't you
Roger and I said no and she said we've
been at the Friends Meeting House that
is where the Quakers meet she said well
as you know I'm an atheist so I can't
subscribe to their religious beliefs but
I will say this they are very very good
people
that's stuck with I can still recount
that story now because it's so important
you don't have to subscribe to people's
beliefs you can I can be a radical
atheist and you can be a Hindu the
important thing is that we're good
people
that we have hearts and that we care
about our brothers and sisters and my
mum did I'm going to tell you one more
mum's story and then I'm gonna and then
I'll stop about mum because this is the
most important bit
I was 13 years old I had just gone
through a phase where I suddenly
realized I was gonna die I don't know if
all adolescents have this existential
crisis in their young in early puberty
but I did and I thought
F me
are we gonna die this is scary as [ __ ]
you know yeah oh I got it and I was it
might have been that or it might have
been something else but anyway something
was worrying me and it was probably more
some kind of political thing that I'd
latched onto maybe through her
and she's and she looked at me and she
said all right I'm going to give you
some advice now
come on Emma
all through your life you're going to be
faced with difficult questions and
you're going to have to figure things
out this is my advice when anything
crops up so it could be israel-powered
it could be anything it doesn't matter
what it is so
you must read read read read read
that's what smokonish was telling me
yeah he had he hadn't he'd only read one
side that's the difference between
Michael's mcconish and me I've tried to
look at all sides of these things so I'm
now a bit more warmed anyway she said
read read and very important learn
everything you can about the subject
that's troubling you and importantly
yeah look at it from both if there's
another opinion make sure you study that
as well blah blah blah it'll take some
time it'll be hard work but when you've
done that the work is over you have done
all the heavy lifting
the rest of it is easy and I went uh
what is the rest of it Mom and she
looked at me and she said
the rest of it well that's simple you do
the right thing